[Music]
foreign
thank you so much for joining me on
20-minute leaders it is such a pleasure
to have you
thank you for having me of course where
are you calling from
uh california from silicon valley the
heart of silicon valley
you know yeah in silicon valley but now
it's a shelter in place and
everything's remote yeah from home from
home
well you know let's hope that by the
time this airs then everything is back
to normal
uh but we'll just write the optimism
wave on this and
metal oracle roche global head of
marketing
medicine so much to talk about can you
just give me a brief rundown of
who you are and how you got to where you
are today
sure um well
you know it's really interesting i was
so fortunate
throughout my life to have uh really
great opportunities that presented
themselves so
i had uh i had um
the opportunity to work in wall street
in silicon valley
and now in a global
pharmaceutical companies you know and
that's uh
really i mean the interesting thing is
is really about passion you know the one
thing that
really drives me is my passion and my
passion for
really understand people so when you
understand people
you you can understand everything and
and you can move everything so
um throughout my career in marketing
leadership
it's really it was really the driver to
understand the social
social psychology of what drive what
drives the individual
what what actually holds back the
individual from
buying decisions or from other things
and uh
the second passion that i have is my
relationship
is my the people that are around me that
i love living with i love working with
and uh
and the third one is is really data
i became a data nerd i became an
insights nerd and i realized how data
and that digital transformation actually
helped
um few industries right when i was
working in jp morgan i was fortunate to
be part of this
uh digital transformation of
building the drill down investment you
know for
institutional investors etc and then
in marketing when we used to have ads
and now we have
metrics to understand how to
you know how to create messages that
resonates and you can see
our hearts heart and head and body works
all together on conversion rate
and now in medicine the data changes
everything
and data and what it's beyond the data
it's really how you connect the dots so
that's my
uh passion that actually brought me to
where i am now
okay i already have so many questions
just from that minute brief
er i don't even know where to start
let's go with
uh with social psychology and medicine
and being a global head of marketing for
such a huge company like roche
how do you even go about trying to
understand what consumers
think love adore engage with
yeah so first of all i'm just going to
make a correction i'm not the global
head of marketing of all rows it's just
that the digital
uh aspect of it and uh only the digital
aspect of it okay
sure yeah let's put it that way so
digital now changing medicine as we know
it today right
so uh yeah i mean um
if you think about that we're trying to
understand the
in in understanding in social psychology
we're trying to understand the makeup
of the human right what drives women to
make
certain decisions that behave certain
behaviors
and how do we really resonate
with this individual and then later on
as segments
to uh to drive a certain behaviors as a
marketeers as a business leader etc
so in medicine it's almost the same you
know we're trying to understand
the the biology trying to understand the
genetic makeup we're trying to
understand the the clinical makeup that
makes the human
as it is for personalized care and and
think about that i'm
parallelizing it right now in marketing
so driving personalized
messaging and driving personalized
healthcare so there is a lot of
connections in many ways and it's all
about
you know the technology that's enabling
us to do that so how do you use digital
transformation in
really understanding not just the human
but the segment of people or sub
populations and
how do you actually uh
resonate with them and you know it's
it's it's very clear to me i think and i
think it's the right intuition
that when you look at so the social
psychology and
what innately motivates people in
medicine marketing
it's very different from you know when
you're trying to sell sales force or
when trying to sell
any other b2c product that you can find
in the supermarket or an electronics
store
so how is it more complicated is it very
different
good question so there are certain
things you know that you need to
think about you know who's the buyer is
it
consumers is it uh is it
a patient is it is it a
company right so you know we we're very
it's very interesting time point in time
right now to be living in because the
technology helps you
actually with social psychology with the
selling process with the
with the res you know the resonance of
what you're trying to sell so
you know if you think about if you think
about
software right now because we are in
time of pandemic right
the acceleration of innovation is huge
in healthcare
right so even if it's a medicine
development or software development for
all these healthcare workers and
professionals
to to set to buy new technologies
because they need that
so that was like a really um
opportunity actually for the small
companies to come with new
technologies that helps you know and if
you think about human psychology if i
was a cio right now
in a hospital in a healthcare
environment
i need to provide the right technology
so
how do you connect actually with those
people
and to drive them to buy your technology
and i think this is a good time for
startups that have yeah you know really
nice
virtual digital this is the point of
acceleration
yeah i actually just had a fascinating
chat with alyssa rapp who's a
lecturer at stanford business school and
in chicago booth and she
says very similarly there are startups
that yeah it's it's hard to raise
capital
people have to bootstrap right now but
there are startups who need to take a
step back and understand
we can actually put the gas pedal on
right now this is our attempt to
accelerate
innovation and really adopt the new
market that's forming here
metal but all that is true and you know
if i have a team of five six people and
a startup i make the decisions it's all
easy
we're talking about a big company we're
talking about huge corporates
with huge ladders of decision making so
how do you go about doing that
yeah you know you can see that um
you can see different companies
different brands actually reinventing
themselves we're thinking about their
mission
rethinking how they actually what's
their purpose in life and then
you know as a brand you need to think of
what is your identity and how do you
go beyond selling a product right now
to really understand what's the goal of
your target audience
you really understand who is your
audience and how can you connect
beyond the product right now so i think
as a big
company you really need to understand
how to connect and and sometimes it's
not the selling point sometimes
it's just who you are as
as a brand as a company and what's your
mission
so um you know being exposed to
quite a few companies actually during
time of uh
of crisis being in wall street during
the meltdown
and being here now in healthcare in the
eye of the storm of health care of this
pandemic of kobe 19
with the scale of it you know you really
need
to give time to rethink your strategy
and rethink and reflect on it and really
connect at the higher level at the
purpose level at the mission level
wow that actually builds trust for the
big company that they're not
opportunistic and they're really trying
to
um to resonate and and keep resilience
and be constructive and be positive and
and show you know the together
and the shared purpose with their
customers
you know it's an interesting thing to
think about
um across the globe right now we all
have
shared experience yeah this is like
unique so rare
so rare you know we all have the same
goal of
fighting kovic 19. since when we all
have this goal together
if you're in italy africa or japan or
silicon valley we all actually at the
same situation and
and i think companies starting to
understand and pivot right
right now to to connect with their
audience and this is the social
psychology at the end of the day
you know beyond product how important is
it in your mind for
for the average ceo or entrepreneur to
to have a good grasp on social
psychology and a lot of these innate
mechanisms that you're
you're touching upon yeah i think that
um every ceo really needs to have
a really good understanding of people
and
of uh more than just a person they
really need to understand
what drives their target audience who do
they
talk to what's it's not it's beyond the
persona you know where people talk about
yeah i created like a persona i can
teach
right do you really need to have this
human-to-human connection and it doesn't
matter
in in what setting if it's small startup
or a big
corporation if you really don't
understand who is
in front of you and what their you know
hierarchy of needs if it's maslow or
another
yeah yeah you can't really sell so
every ceo really need to understand the
human part and the soft skills and
what what drives this person in front of
you so
and and navigate through different times
hard times good times
no and you know this sounds like a skill
i'm actually enrolling
in the summer in a social psychology
class at stanford but i'm also coming in
with the humility of understanding that
probably the only real way to practice
it and to understand it is to then just
be a leader
whether it's you know being a commander
in the israeli army or any other army or
going and leading teams and companies
later on
and i and it to me it just makes so much
sense that
this is one of the key elements of being
a good entrepreneur and a good founder
just knowing who you're speaking to know
your audience know how to lead them what
motivates them
and and i definitely this is something
that i'm taking to heart i'd love to
hear a little bit about what it was like
being in wall street
in the meltdown i don't get to hear that
very often
i was too young back then too yeah
that was uh quite an experience let's
say
that's now that i'm watching the all the
movies that came
after yeah it's with me it really speaks
to me because like
i was right in the heart of it that you
know i was working with jp morgan at the
time
in new york city um
it was like you know pulling hair for a
few days
coming we you know people were so
nervous
uh you know i started at the hype of
wall street you know when all
you know everything that you think about
investment bankers and
uh it really you know some movies really
reflected on that
very accurately um it was
tough it was not an easy experience you
know it was very
um very hardening you know people worked
their whole life on things and then from
the banking perspective
you you see you know you you can connect
those numbers to actually people's lives
you know and and
you see the magnitude of of what
what it means to actually being on the
other side
it's not uh it's not a simple thing to
do you kind of almost need to disconnect
your personal life from looking at those
numbers
definitely you know going back to the
digital transformation with medicine and
and some of the questions that you're
that you're working on right now
give me a little bit of insight into
into your work and and what are what are
the big transformations that are
happening
is it is it different in medicine and
marketing digitally in medicine than it
is to in other in other ways
yeah so you know just um
just to give like a context into what's
going on today in medicine and
technology and
you know so there's medicine and and the
the
biggest driver right now and the biggest
innovation
in diagnostics and treatment decisions
in
in monitoring in in the hospital and
outside the hospital
really is um the nexus of
of the scientific discoveries the
technologies that enable them
and actually the medicine you know so
let me give you like a little bit of
some data you know if you were an
oncologist
uh coming out of uh med school like
let's say in the 50s
medical knowledge um it took medical
knowledge to double itself
about 50 years 50.
if you graduated from med school in 2010
it would take for medical knowledge to
double itself about two years
nowadays it's 73 days
73 days for medical knowledge to double
itself
so wow how can one compute
all that how can the brain the human
brain actually
make a decision when you know everything
is obsolete
more and more and more information in
you know in shapes of
of uh scientific discoveries and shape
of
papers that are being published so this
is the
avalanche of data in medicine right
it's it's staggering you know so the
knowledge gap is
is growing so you need technologies
really to close this gap and there are
technologies nowadays right
so this is one of the biggest
challenges in medicine today you know
how do you get
how do you enable as a healthcare
institute how do you enable your
teams and your doctors and
and and care teams to really make right
decisions so
um so that's the trend and now
if you think about the technologies that
enable the
scientific discoveries like let's say
the genomic
evolution you know not just the we map
the genome that's great but
now we we can see specific it's
personalized medicine
for precision medicine that you can see
specific mutations in specific
disease so the knowledge of the biology
and all that
is also growing so very interesting how
this three of technology scientific
discoveries and medical innovation
coming together
and this is where the innovation happens
if it's
forms of ai that collects data that
analyze the data
that predicts certain things to have
that's happening
if it's if it's virtual you know virtual
tools right now
that yeah that allows you to connect
with the different specialties and and
make the right decisions and hear
different things so anyway but there's a
the
this is the trend this is where we're
going it's really bringing data
and creating more of the personalized
medicine
sure so is it is it more so that
you know 50 years ago when you wanted to
develop a new insight into what's
happening in the medicine arena
the new was mostly you know intuition
guesswork
some case studies and today it's really
the knowledge is there it's hidden
a needle in a haystack of piles
of of data that's accumulated every year
and it's really a race
between companies to understand the data
and make sense of it is that where we
are today
so i think it's it's really there's a
lot of technology that exists right now
i don't know if it's
i don't think it's actually a
competition i think it's a collaboration
because oh okay
nobody can really you know solve
all the problems in the world that it
just doesn't exist so i think what we
see today
actually is interesting collaborations
that
complement each other to really bring a
solution for this problem of this
gap of data so data you're right data is
siloed and data has different standards
and you can compare apples to
oranges when it comes to data but then
when companies
work with each other then actually
that's where the insight sits
so of course we are in
a market and there's a competition and
sometimes you see two companies working
on the same spot but
yeah but it really is the the
the beauty actually of what's gonna
happen
is that the sharing and collaborations
insights
because it happens in silos and we know
if
a healthcare goal is is really
provide the better health the better
health
happens in this synergies
i love it i love it method thank you so
so much for this time before we leave
and i can't believe 20 minutes are
already up but before we leave i want to
put you on the spot
one time and i want you to tell me three
words that you would best describe
yourself as i actually already know the
words from the very first
answer that you gave me in this talk but
i'd love to hear those words anyways
and so go ahead
yeah good uh another good question
so i think i think really one of the
things is like i said from the beginning
it's passion yeah and the second thing
is resilience
i think of uh resilience and curiosity
you know definitely and you also
mentioned relationships that are
so so important to you
love it so much amital thank you so much
for the time uh thank you for all the
work that you're doing during these
during these very difficult times and i
know you're working on very interesting
things that unfortunately we weren't
able to
to discuss here but i can't wait to see
them one day
and thank you and stay safe
thank you
you